9 awakes the struggle for the soul of a
rising power his talk from 1994 lasts
about an hour Nicholas Kristof co-author
of China wakes who was Harold Hsu Harold
was a young man who his family believed
very much in the Communist Party and he
was the youngest foreign ministry
diplomat when he first joined the
foreign ministry after the Communist
revolution
he became the English interpreter for Jo
mi and occasionally for Mao Zedong
himself you know he was a real star and
somebody who would have risen I think
perhaps all the way perhaps to be
Foreign Minister then he made the
mistake on a trip to on a trip to India
with foreign minister Jo and lie of
buying some shirts and going to a movie
with with foreign ministry funds and he
thought well I'll just pay them back and
then he also made the mistake of telling
the Indian government Jo analyzed
preferences for food and color to make
gel and lies stay a little more
comfortable well the result was when he
got back to Beijing he was reported he
was sent off to prison for 10 years his
career destroyed and after he was
finally released from prison he was sent
off to a village in remote part of China
to work for 10 more years throughout
throughout too much of the Cultural
Revolution and finally in I believe 1978
trying to desperately needed English
teachers and here they had you know
somebody who had been one of the great
English speakers in the country and an
interpreter for Mao and they found him
in this remote village and brought him
back but I remember maybe the most
poignant thing was when he was telling
me the story he had talked about his
mother and how how he had begged the
authorities not to tell his mother about
his arrest and about his imprisonment
and at the very end I thought back about
her and I said well you know so did they
tell your mother and he said that they
had
what happened and he said that she was
so horrified by his by his fall that she
had committed suicide and that he had
his father had written him a note in
prison to tell him about this how did
you meet him he was a friend of ours
this book is really about our friends in
China and to a great extent and he was
one of our friends in China and somebody
we became very close to and you know I
always wondered because you know if he
had become Foreign Minister though this
was a time when the Foreign Ministry was
denouncing us is calling us in for these
struggle sessions with them and I always
wondered you know if he had become
foreign minister would he be announcing
us as well and that I am now he's okay
he's living freely in Beijing and in
some ways I kind of figured that this
whole brutal experience that he went
through in some sense freed him know you
mentioned Joe and why who was he
Joe and I was the Prime Minister and
foreign minister and then effectively
the number two to Mao Zedong and when
did Harold Hsu work for him throughout
the essentially the mid fifties until
his imprisonment in 1957 and you wrote
this book with your wife and you did
each you know a chapter and then she did
another chapter how did you decide which
chapters to write we a part of it was
that and we wanted to preserve her own
voices and there were some things that I
felt more passionate about some things
that Jarrell felt more passionate about
and a part of it was simply arbitrary
Cheryl for example was particular
interested in the plight of Chinese
women and she had her own experiences as
a chinese-american woman and so that was
natural for her I had been on Kinnaman
square when the troops have been fires
of a chapter about
Kahneman and history was more of a
natural for me you speak Chinese speak
Chinese where'd you learn it mostly in
Taiwan but also just a function of
living in China for five years and
spending you know just about every night
with Chinese friends gossiping about
this about that
about their likes and dislikes Sheryl
WuDunn where's the name come from
oh well that's I found that when I went
to China on my first visit I remember I
am a third generation Chinese American
and grew up in New York City and had no
interest in going to the countryside but
Nicholas crust I've actually encouraged
me to go and I remember driving down
that path we were driving through this
scattered rice paddies it was a land
away from what I had grown up what I had
grown up in and we got to the small
little village at the edge of a at the
edge of a little lake and there I was
standing in in the in the village and I
was must have been two feet taller than
almost everybody else there and the
women there were all gray-haired and the
children were tiny tiny little kids and
and I thought this is the village where
my father's father was from and I didn't
think that I had any relatives there I
was sure I had nothing in common with
these people
and as I talked and talked and I told
them who my grandfather was they said
yes yes I am your distant cousin a woman
said as she stepped forward and I was
shocked she had a different last name of
course her in Cantonese her last name
was I'm going to pronounce it's going to
sound awkward mmm and it was from there
that I found the story of how my name
had had become well done
what had happened was that my
grandfather had bought some papers which
was common in those days to go overseas
to to the US and the papers had the same
last name because in Cantonese my name
the first part of my name is hmm and he
got to Ellis Island and he said well my
name isn't done look now that just
really means like Uncle Sam
and they didn't hear that I had no idea
what it was I didn't know what to do
with it so they just heard the done they
said oh your name is done so my
grandfather for the longest time was
William done
and finally after getting all these
phone calls people calling up and saying
are you done and then hang up
he decided well he's going to take the
Menor pronunciation of his name and call
it Wu done so that's how I'm done now
you found out something about your
grandfather didn't particularly care for
yes I did it was um rather shocking
while I was there I discovered that he
had had a another wife a wife before my
grandmother and that in fact they had
both gone to the US the first wife and
my grandfather and she bore him two
daughters but no son and so they went
back to China and on that trip he
decided to leave her there I she wasn't
going to be able to bear him any more
sons he thought and so he took another
wife and brought her back to the US and
had three children including my father
so it was a very rude awakening to
discover that he had essentially
abandoned his first wife he never saw
her again and she stayed there until she
died in the in the 1960s how did you two
meet we were in Los Angeles I was
working for the New York Times Sheryl
for The Wall Street Journal and so we
started this incredibly complicated
courtship whereby we couldn't really
talk about what either of us was doing
and you know I would leave messages with
Sheryl at the Wall Street Journal it
just is Nick why did what was the
attraction what was the attraction to
him yes oh well of course and he was
this famous reporter I remember in the
bureau and see he was the only business
reporter for the New York Times in LA
and our bureau at The Wall Street
Journal had nine people there they were
all covering the same exact events that
he was with him all the same news news
events and oh quite often we would open
the paper in the morning these that
Christophe how did he do this and all
five of them would be
gathered around the newspaper article
trying to figure out how did this one
guy beat nine other reporters in the
bureau
now when did you marry in 1988 just as
we were leaving to China China was our
honeymoon your honeymoon so to speak in
the first seven months we're just a
wonderful wonderful time now we arrived
in November 1988 literally fresh from
our honeymoon just after getting married
and then always it's the most open time
in China's history we could go off and
see friends we we would have lunch with
just about anybody we wanted to one time
we drove a friend back in to gemenon hai
the Chinese leadership compound which is
like the Kremlin and you know it was all
okay then until Tiananmen then what then
overnight everything changed I mean we
were changed I it is an absolutely
transforming experience when you're on
Kinnaman square and you are being shot
at by these troops and you're seeing
kids around you killed but more I mean
that was one night or killing one on a
few days but what was incense more
traumatic almost for us was just the the
the way the whole repressive apparatus
clamped down on us and you know we were
followed every time we leave our
apartment we'd have these government
goons behind us you know a couple of
cars couple motorcycles I trying to
figure out our sources and you know our
phones were tapped rooms were bugged
office was broken into we were called in
to the foreign ministry regularly to be
denounced to is the worst thing was his
fear of getting your friends in trouble
when did you leave China permanently
1993 at the end of 1993 and this book
that you've written did you spend time
doing only that yes we did we sent a few
months while we were still in China
working just on the book I mean the book
is the culmination of our five years
there we heard hundreds of stories from
all the people we met and we we've had
many many different experiences and we
wanted trynna to come alive to Americans
we wanted we wanted to tell the stories
of the many different Chinese that we
the minister that you danced with that
was interesting
in fact they can I had a very good
partnership because there were times
when the Chinese wanted to meet a
foreigner but and they call they call
him a big nosed foreigner big nosed
American I could write a news for
instance when he went to Beijing
University and he would do interviews
students knew that he wasn't a spy but
me they make they weren't always so sure
but there were other times when they
didn't want to speak to a foreigner they
didn't want to get caught with a
foreigner and so I could slip into their
homes and learn their secrets I remember
one time I was researching the topic of
sexual harassment in the status of women
and I found myself at a dinner dance
party and a cabinet minister asked me to
dance he apparently thought that I was a
local secretary or something and as soon
as we got out onto the dance floor he
tried to force himself upon me I was
shocked but it gave me tremendous
insight into the status of women into
how women are treated and how cabinet
ministers look upon them as perks
certainly a non Chinese wouldn't have
been able to have that kind of
experience what kind of an accent do you
have it's very interesting the nice
thing about China is that it's such a
vast country that full of so many
different dialects that if you're in the
north people will say oh you have a
southern accent if you're in this South
people say oh you have a Western accent
it was very very useful you went on a
trip once and as a tourist while you're
a reporter why did you have to do that
because if you're a reporter then every
time you leave Beijing and go somewhere
else in China you have to go through
official you have to go through the
Foreign Ministry and get their
permission what that means is then it
will a they may deny you the right to go
but secondly even if they give you the
right they're gonna meet you at the
airport take you to a hotel often they
stay in the hotel room right next to
yours they booked up every moment of
your time
and they arrange all of your interviews
and it just really becomes a farce
you know you they I remember once asking
to interview some poor peasants and you
know so I go to a poor part of China
they take me off into the countryside
there about you know ten officials
trailing me
and we pull and I knew there was a
problem when we this poor peasant so to
speak lived in this you know huge
courtyard I had a motorcycle and you
know a beautiful place it and so Cheryl
and I increasingly decided that if we
were gonna convey the reality of China
we pretty much had to break the rules
and we had to go out into the
countryside without these people
following us and that's why we did it
where did you go on this one particular
trip I remember you said you went down
11 flights of stairs two from your
apartment to read the security people
right they were there were cameras in
the elevators and so I didn't want to
tip them off and of course that meant
also and I couldn't arrange any of the
tickets on the telephone which was
bugged or you know or in the apartment
or in the office but I got them
separately and then went down the stairs
hid as the car left the compound because
there were cameras and guards at the
gate of the compound where we were
forced to live and went off to the
airport and I went to seems young on
that trip it's like a Muslim to bed it's
the far northwest of China and is the
position of a Turkish area where there
had been an incipient rebellion and the
authorities had refused for years to let
me go so I went anyway and they never
figured it out after I got back and
after they'd read the stories in the New
York Times they sure Pickard it out and
they called me in and complained
vigorously I argued that what I had done
was legal because I said I had gone as a
tourist and once I was there I decided
that this was very interesting and that
therefore I wanted to write about it and
so I said well it wasn't a reporting
trip it was a a trip as a tourist which
by my definition was legal they didn't
see it that way and did I gather that
you've been to all 30 provinces right
how about you oh not as many but I what
1819 I don't remember how often did you
travel together never almost never never
never
Oh one time we did travel to these to
the seaside resort of Bayda huh
and that was because I found a political
story to write and he found her travel
story trying to bedroom it that was
about it but mainly the problem was that
one
was always on the Dung's helping
Deathwatch in Beijing you know we we
were sent to Beijing to cover the you
know that the post dumb China and kept
waiting for him to die we didn't want to
be both caught out in the provinces when
he did die done Xiao Peng is what who is
it you want to know what his only formal
title is he is the honorary chairman of
the bridge Association cards so it
really shouldn't matter what happens to
the honorary chairman the bridge
Association right you call him an
emperor yes okay of course he is the
Emperor of China and an emperor in China
rules until he dies so essentially when
dong dies that I think it will have
far-reaching change for China we may not
see it immediately
for instance if he dies Monday we may
not see anything on Thursday in the same
way that Brezhnev's death laid the
groundwork for some remarkable change in
the Soviet Union
it wasn't immediate but we saw we saw
what happened evolved no how old is he
in this picture that we just saw ah that
is in 1990 so he was 86 he's 90 this
year you went to his own town I went to
his hometown it was the very interesting
trip he has never been back he left when
he was about 16 years old and never
turned back never been to his parents
grave never been to his parents grave
which is very unusual in China because
there's a certain holiday a certain part
of the year where they specifically go
to the graves of their ancestors and
sweep the graves what does that say
about him what I what I think it says is
that his relationship with his family
which was basically a middle-class
family of the local local landlords it
was a very tenuous one he I think was
partly embarrassed by the fact that he
came from a nice fairly wealthy
background and here he was a
revolutionary a communist and it was
very must have been very difficult for
hiccup him to reconcile that
and he probably was very very busy what
are you all doing now we're studying
Japanese now the new york times are
gonna send us to tokyo to be
correspondence there also as a couple
beginning the beginning of next year
how often there's a new york times a lot
of couples to do this it's becoming more
common there there are now a few couples
there's also a couple in moscow for
example and and there have been a few
here and there and how did you get to
report how did how did you get to the
new york times after you've been through
all street journal oh I got married
basically I was them I had had
internships throughout the country and
then I went to Hong Kong but I got
married and then Nick was sent to
Beijing and I started stringing for the
new times and then just strung my way
onto the times at some point you said
that Abe Rosenthal told you to forget
everything he'd ever read or heard about
China before he used to be the executive
editor the New York Times
what was the point the point was not to
be intimidated by the fact that
everybody else had been writing about
China for years and knew a lot about it
he just had to go there and you know see
what you see and smell what you smell in
this room right about that right about
that Tablo out there and I think it was
great advice when you went back to your
home where your ancestors were from what
what did you see well I mean talk about
it in terms of what we have in our lives
here in this country I see well the
village that I saw in my father's
village is is very very backward even
though it's in the southern part of
China I was just devastated how poor the
huts were they were made out of brick
and stones put together and sometimes
they were painted yellow or or gray and
we have a map here and we're gonna show
that you have at the front of the book
and I want you to show me if you can
where your home is on this map okay well
right here doctor son and how did you
get there
we took a Nick was with me which okay
van well we of course we got to
Guanzhong we got to we I'm sorry we got
first to Macau from Macau we took
a taxi and we drove through the winding
winding dirt paths and Guangdong
province and got to my my the County Tai
Shan and then got to my village what did
you notice about your wife as she was
approaching her ancestral home the two
was getting I think a combination of
sentimental and kind of jittery about
what she would find and and also I think
just appalled by the extent to which you
know these were barefoot peasants in
every direction and that's what you
found that's what I found
yes oh yeah I mean a lot of times they
were barefoot or they had sandals that
were ripped up and it hadn't been having
it probably ten years old and their
clothes were shabby and I mean I wore my
sort of worse clothes I just worked my
the rag the rags that I could find and I
still felt as though I had just walked
out of Bloomingdale's it was very sad to
see that because I had had so much here
I had grown up in the States I was
educated at private schools I I took
French and I know shopped at Macy's and
Saks and here was my distant cousin who
was 60 years old because in China of
course they the generations they have
kids at a younger age and there he was
he couldn't even write his name when I
asked him for his address ins name he
had to ask someone else to write it down
for him where did you go to school here
in the States
I went to a school called fields in High
School in New York City and then where I
met I went to Cornell University got a
degree in what it intellectual history
and your parents are still in New York
City they are still in New York City
what did they do or do what do they do
for a living
oh they're they're in business they have
their private businesses and and why did
they come here in the first place they
were actually born well my father was
born in the States my mother was born in
Canada but my grandfather came over
because at that time everybody had
looked at the US as the golden land
everybody wanted to leave China and
that's the sad thing because back then
this was in the 1920s people were
leaving China because they thought there
was no opportunity there and that's
still going on even in China today even
though China now is
a remarkable country going through an
enormous economic revolution people
still look at America as the land of
opportunity you're from what part of
this country I'm a farm boy Morgan town
of Iain Hill Oregon population 600 and
I'm four miles away from that and where
did you go to college Harvard how did
you get there what was it I mean you
know Oregon to Harvard's a long way well
it helped tremendously my parents are
academics and they teach in Portland
which is about an hour away from the
farm and so you know they always have
encouraged me to think about you know
first grade college isn't selling and
and I think it helped that that Harvard
is probably looking for Oregon farm boys
to round it out what did you do after
that
then I went off to Oxford on a road
scholarship to study law at that time
lost and terribly interesting then I
studied law and decided it wasn't did
you get a law degree a British law
degree yeah again can you practice law
in the United States no I couldn't I
there are a couple of states where I
could take the bar exam right oh I never
took the bar I think and Nevada I could
take the bar exam in there in New York
I'd have to I think go to some kind of
committee and request permission when
you got to your wife's village what was
it what are the things looking back on
that did you remember on I just remember
thinking he'll think ahead Cheryl's
grandfather left and I remember also
thinking that I under what had happened
to the person who had sold
Cheryl's grandfather the papers that
he'd used to get to the US you know here
was somebody else who had the right to
come to the US and he had sold those
papers and I wondered if his grandkids
were there in the village you know
barefoot and and and he listened not
very well educated because perhaps their
grandfather you know wanted some cash at
the time carpeting on the floor cars in
the village stoves in the house
refrigerators none of that none of it
none of that when I went there in 1987
there was none of that were no
refrigerators they cooked on a very very
primitive I think they had their own
coal with it which they
cook on but it was very primitive and I
mean there sometimes the stones or the
bricks would would would fall out when
it rotted away and they had no money to
repair it
they had chickens they had pig living
right in their front yard I mean it's
not really a yard it's just in front of
the house that was in 1987 it's very
different now China has just the D and
the astronomic strides a remarkable I
went back there and in 1993 as well back
to your home I went back there to see
what it changed
well I one family there was having a
celebration because the grandchild in
the family was one month old that's
tradition in China and so I there was a
big banquet going on and everybody from
villages in the area we're coming and
they were sitting down to an
eight-course meal eating all sorts of
things they were eating meat almost of
chicken they were eating pork they were
eating all sorts of vegetables and
mushrooms they have done that in 87 with
one month celebration they would have
celebrated it but not nearly as much as
they I mean maybe they would have had
their few greens or vegetables because
they are they are farmers basically and
so they do produce their own food so
they will have a lot of vegetables and
rice and and but and not much meat at
that time but there would have had
something they would have had some meat
whose Gregory Gregory's our elder son
he's that two and a half years old town
there's a oh well that's a very
interesting because then you have
another son yeah there's another one
Jeffrey he was just four months old and
then how did you do this in the middle
of all these this activity over there I
mean what was where was Gregory born it
was funny I mean you know you figured
that there what 20 million babies born
in China each year and that it should be
no problem but we kind of figured that
Aris we wanted born in Hong Kong so he
was born in Hong Kong and then the
Chinese authorities refused to give him
a visa he'd get into China well we got
him a tourist visa through a friendly
travel agent where the Chinese call
door and got in this and then sort of
smuggled him into China on this tourist
visa and then the foreign ministry
refused to give him a residence permit
the the foreign ministry was mad at us
at that point for some articles that
we'd written about the Prime Minister
leepung and so they wouldn't give
Gregory his permit Sheryl ended up
taking Gregory knows tiny baby and in
swaddling clothes to the foreign
ministry to see if he would melt their
hearts you know or poo on them at least
he didn't work he neither worked
they had no hearts to meld what is it
what is it you did that made the foreign
ministry some ad it was an article that
Nick had written but I think beyond that
it was one particular article about
leepung and in leepung who is the prime
minister hardliner eye of china somebody
who had played a major role in the
Kinnaman crackdown somebody who comes
across as as arrogant as unfriendly
extremely unpalatable politician miss
reads words every once in a while the
Chinese always laugh when he trying to
when he's reading a speech and he hasn't
memorized of course but he got the text
in front of him and he mistreats a
character and they all laugh he's in
this picture right there on the left
that's the president Jeong Simon oh I'm
sorry I get the wrong picture
how does he become Prime Minister well
he benefited greatly because he was
Gellin lies adopted son and Dylan lies
widow helped him out a great deal I mean
it you know the communist has become a
little more like a dynasty and that
nepotism helps tremendously those kinds
of connections to previous leaders
helped a great deal well when you wrote
the article how did you know right away
or how soon did you know that they
didn't like the article um well we later
heard that what happened was that leap
Hong's office know called up the foreign
ministry to berate them you know how can
you allow these reporters christoph moo
done to be writing these kind of
slanderous attacks and so the foreign
ministry called me in to complain about
that article they
oh they broke into our office they
ordered the tax Bureau to audit our
taxes the surveillance on us just
increased dramatically so we know we
would have even more people tailing us
whatever we went out it showed up pretty
quickly speaking of your son you wanted
this your son to be delivered in Hong
Kong how come I had visited a number of
hospitals in Beijing just to check this
out I was also writing a story about the
issue and so I thought I would take an
opportunity to to look at the maternity
wards and I it was perfectly fine I'm
sure that I would have had no problem
but I just thought what if what if I
needed sort of immediate surgery or
something like that I just didn't want
to have surgery in China okay because I
just didn't like there was there was a
risk that I didn't want to take and it
was my first child I had not been
through this experience before I was a
jittery expectant mother I thought Hong
Kong was the better way to go and I had
a lot of other reporters that had had
done the same thing they'd gone down to
Hong Kong and so there was a tradition
of people based in Beijing going down to
Hong Kong to have their babies how do
you think the Chinese like your book I
we've had very good response from
ordinary Chinese you know from friends
I don't know how officials will like it
I mean we come to very optimistic
conclusions but we also go through a lot
of the Communist Party's dirty laundry
we have every reason to be down on China
when we were there when we just got
there kids were killed on Tiananmen
Square my husband was shot at my son was
effectively banned we have friends who
are thrown in prison and they're still
there but despite all that we think that
the most important thing going on in
China today is this economic revolution
and it's probably the most important
thing going on the world today
how could you explain more about the
economic revolution how does it manifest
itself well one way of looking at it is
that the US has been the biggest economy
in the world in last for the last
hundred years or so ever since we took
over from great
Britain and now China is poised to take
over that role ultra surpassed the US as
the world's biggest economy sometime in
the next five decades and you know you I
think that's one index that China's
growing importance you can also look at
the fact that China has the world's
biggest army the world's fastest growing
military budget in sports you know
Chinese women distance runners just came
out of nowhere last year to redefine our
understanding of the human potential I
think an broad range of areas we're
seeing the consequences of this you know
of the 15 years of extraordinary
economic growth in China what did you
see change from 87 to 93 oh I remember
when we first went in 87 and we were
interviewing rich peasants these are
official officially chosen which
peasants of course they would want us to
see the best they were making the
average or equivalent of 100 US dollars
two hundred US dollars a month now
in 1993 I Nick actually met someone who
as a furniture business he's a peasant
as well and he has got a ten story
building that overlooks the rice paddies
and his assets are worth 40 million US
dollars and I know someone who went to
the real estate business and in two
years has accumulated a Empire worth a
hundred million dollars you tell the
story and hear of an Italian Chinese
deal great that turned on something
familiar yeah yeah I mean I suppose it
should be kind of a cautionary tale for
American businesses because it you know
it shows the way things can take a
strange turn this was a Italian company
that was working out a joint venture in
Hunan province to make syringes and a
Italian bank had arranged to make an 18
million dollar loan to finance the
venture now as part of that they agreed
to send the Chinese managing director
and his assistants to Rome for the
signing and the Chinese company also
insisted on sending the managing
directors a beautiful assistant you know
who had no clear responsibilities but
the Italian firm the Italian bank agreed
I yes
common in China with joint ventures that
the porn company will pay an extra
$100,000 in costs to send the Chinese
abroad and then they get next for
$200,000 in pricing on the deal so in
this case the Italian bank paid for
several people from the Chinese company
to go to you know the established
Italian business centers like like
Venice and Florence and they ended up in
Rome and the date of the signing came
for the deal and the Chinese managing
director just refused to sign and you
know he didn't explain why and the
Italians are all in a tizzy and they
keep probing and well finally they
figure out what the problem is the
Chinese managing director wants this
beautiful assistant of his to spend the
night with him and she's refusing and
he's blackmailing her by saying that
he's not gonna sign the loan agreement
and they're not going to be able to
return to China unless she yields well
the Italians get wind of this and you
know they see a stalemate that could go
on for months meanwhile they're paying
all the hotel bills they began to get
kind of nervous they and they were
suggesting that you know maybe they
could supply some professionals for this
this man and no he was adamant I he he
just wanted his assistant well it ended
in because the finally the Italians
reminded the guy that if he went ahead
with the deal they were going to give
him a hundred and forty thousand dollar
cash payment directly to him under the
table you know nominally a consulting
fee basically he was abroad if he went
ahead and so he did he signed the deal
they all went back to China and you know
that and they lived happily ever after
not quite all right well the situation
wasn't ideal it wasn't ideal in the
sense that obviously the man wasn't
punished and in fact he nine hundred and
eighty thousand dollars as his as his
commission as his bribe but also I think
if you look a little more closely there
was some progress in the sense that and
the woman was able to fight back in a
way that she probably would have not
have been able to in earlier years and
if the man tries to punish her if he
tries to kick her out of her job well
she can get another job at another
company if he puts a nasty note in her
personnel file then you know personnel
files don't really matter anymore and so
I you know she has alternatives in a way
that in Maoist China she never would
have she got compensation for pain and
suffering from but from the foreign side
this is China but that's China I mean if
there is evil there is corruption there
scandal but there is progress at the end
of your book you write about the last
dinner would you tell us that story
oh yes after five years and well for us
five years but every correspondent
before they leave they have a dinner
with the foreign ministry in which they
basically receive a nice plaque of the
great wall and shake hands and smile a
lot and take a very buoyant message
about China back to the US so we had our
meal at the same time there was a our
handler mr. Chow and another woman who
he brought with him and we were sitting
at the table and we were all smiles and
talking about very light conversation
and he all of a sudden brings up the
fact that mr. Christophe and you went to
Shindong province without approval well
this is where we got scolded for niks
having gone on a tourist trip and and
writing about it and then he speaking
Chinese at this time oh yes yeah we were
speaking in Chinese and then he started
braiding us for how we have damaged
sino-us relations and it was all and
then I just stopped eating the shrimps I
just didn't feel like eating anything
and the poor woman was embarrassed she
just looked down straight down on her
table refused to look at either of us or
even mr. Joe and just
you know just kept eating as though
nothing was going on she literally had
tuned out and he just kept going on and
on and we were just horrified and we
thought well let's just smile and you
know swallow our food and switch to
English because we thought that maybe if
we started speaking in English he would
feel a little bit awkward and wouldn't
be able to criticize us so much we did
that a little bit and then the dinner
was over and just sort of ran away and
it was really a mistake on their part I
mean the Chinese government always seems
to put its worst foot forward they have
an impeccably awful sense of public
relations here was an opportunity to
leave us with a nice picture of China
and yet they they ruin it by they
spoiled the dinner and you know leave a
bitter taste in our mouth I'm not sure
that this is accurate but I believe the
largest number of foreign students in
America today are Chinese that's right
why I mean with the picture you paint
and the spies and all that stuff why do
they let their their people come here
and do they follow them around the
United States China you know however
awful its mean right situation maybe is
a lot less awful than it used to be it's
opening up by the day it's becoming you
know the it's it's it's not nearly as
closed as the East European countries
were in indeed you know by and large
Chinese can go abroad now if they want
to and so you have this huge exodus of
around 50,000 Chinese students coming to
the US now once they're are here there
are spies and that who do keep an eye on
others who are politically active they
may get in some trouble if they go back
but again you know that I think the
Communist Party is losing its ability to
either inspire people or E or terrify
them you write that you were sympathetic
to the Communist yeah when I first
arrived in China I had some sympathies
with the Communist revolution I mean
they I think that if I had been a
Chinese in the late 1940s I might well
have been a communist yeah
promised overturned corruption to divide
up the land and it's clear that first
they did a fair amount of good you know
they raised the status that women they
had literacy campaigns all of that what
about you would you have been a
communist no no I I didn't really have
any kind of affinity for that what about
the family when you were growing up oh
my parents were in fact my grandfather
on my mother's side I was on the
welcoming party when for Sun yat-sen the
other side the the time the Taiwan side
so they were not communists who took
your place by the way from the New York
Times in China and can you buy the
International Herald Tribune in any
hotels our successor is a fellow called
Pat Tyler and yeah you can buy at the
Herald Tribune you can buy the Hong Kong
papers you can buy Newsweek and time all
in the Beijing hotels I wrote down the
name our Chiang mm-hmm who was it
he was a man who is a Cantonese and that
means that he is from the southern
province of Guangdong and he lives in
what used to be called can't on but now
everybody refers to a Guangzhou and let
me stop you if you live in one quad done
one dumb province how close to Hong Kong
oh that's very close to it borders on
Hong Kong and that's where my home
village is so people go to Hong Kong
they can get in the train or in a car
and drive right up there right right
okay right and he's a very interesting
case because he every time I meet him
every time I met him he would be richer
he would be more having he would have
all these new business ideas he was a
man who was not very proud democratic he
really cared mostly about coming up
making money and helping his sister is
helping his family along but around the
time of the Tiananmen Square massacre
after the massacre he saw his
opportunity
he saw that now if he could just claim
himself a student or someone who had
supported the movement
and get overseas and claim asylum in the
US then he wouldn't have to go back to
China so he bought a passport fake
passport and that got him to the US
would it cost him forty thousand US
dollars he had that much money then but
when he got there he turned himself in
and he turned himself in because he
couldn't live with favours afraid that
he would be caught with a fake passport
even though he had gotten as far as he
had where did you ever when he went
through not directly to the US he went
through Asia spent some time in
Singapore and Japan and then back then
back to the US and he turned himself in
do he turned himself in to the
authorities to the US authorities and he
thought that they would be sympathetic
to his cause he said that I was a I
sympathized with the students and I
helped them and you know I'm afraid that
all the persecuted if I go back to China
and they didn't pay any attention to him
they sent him on the first they sent him
back to China and he was fined a lot
when he got back to the got back to the
to China and he had nothing with him he
had lost all the money that he had
invested in this infant in this venture
and he had to start from scratch luckily
he was not thrown in prison because we
know other people who have been thrown
into prison but he started from scratch
built up another restaurant business and
he was really lucky he found a great
spot and so one day a foreign venture
came up to foreign investors came up to
him and said we want this spot and we'll
pay you another $40,000 $40,000 for the
spot he took it now he's running all
sorts of businesses now he's going into
the pharmaceutical business he's
smuggling dogs in from into China which
in China it's rather unusual because
Chinese are used to eating dog not
having them as pets he's smuggling them
into China as pets and he says you know
I'm doing something good for China I'm
trying to treat I'm trying to tell
Chinese people that dogs are nice things
as pets not as food speaking of eating
dogs you have a whole section on
cannibalism eating humans what's that
about um that I suppose is a reminder
that you know however all the things are
that used to be a lot more
in the Cultural Revolution when China
was all falling apart in Guang XI which
is in the south of China in the far
south
there were several counties where a
brutality was as great as anywhere and
we got a hold of some documents these
are secret Communist Party documents
that a Chinese writer had given us and
they outlined just extraordinary
brutality they where perhaps the biggest
incident of cannibalism modern times but
it wasn't you know because of famine or
some Thai psychopathic murderer this was
politics what would happen is the Red
Guards that you know Mao's Red Guards
were leading the Cultural Revolution
wouldn't be struggling against some kind
of landlord or somebody they would call
a counter revolutionary they would beat
him to death and then they would have
the crowd eat his flesh is a way of
proving their hatred for this kind of
person and so you had some students you
know roasted their principal in a school
yard and all the students would have to
eat it just to show their their hatred
for these people in one case the first
student takes him flesh from the
principal's body was the boyfriend of
the principal's daughter because he
wanted to show that that he hated that
man that he had no affection for the
family you had what year was the -
during the Great Leap Forward no this
was mostly in 1968 in the Cultural
Revolution it was the Great Leap Forward
that was in 1958 and that's where you
read a lot about the famine yeah that
was the worst famine in world history
now it provoked the worst famine in
world history thirty million people died
why what caused the famine it was a
combination of a lot of factors part of
it was that China had just been
collectivizing its countryside and it
had been paying attention to all these
kinds of grand projects - for example to
have steel mills all throughout the
countryside peasants were ordered to you
know throw in their metal implements
into these backyard steel furnaces and
they they were spending all their times
on these things producing worthless
steel
losing their implements they started all
kinds of no grand projects to build
aqueducts build dams this kind of thing
and they neglected the countryside and
then finally now kind of deceived
himself I mean he he kept telling people
that they just tried hard enough they
could increase grain output you know by
a hundred percent or more and so all the
local officials started and they saw
that if they didn't report these kinds
of outrageous figures then they would be
in trouble so they began reporting to
the center oh yeah that our County's
grain output rose whatever a hundred
percent and so the center began
demanding more grain from the localities
and there wasn't enough to feed the
peasants and you know thirty million
people died you write about it is it
Edgar snow who wrote for Look magazine
who told his audience years ago back in
those days that there was no such thing
as a famine that was one of the scariest
things for us as China watchers that you
know at that time you had a whole Legion
of China watchers travel throughout the
country and Edgar snow was you know the
most prominent of them and they
interviewed people they traveled around
in some cases per month and they
concluded that the one thing they could
be sure of was that there was no famine
going on and obviously in retrospect
they were hoodwinked and Sheryl and I
you know we really began to wonder about
our own ability thirty years later to
really know what was happening
especially in the countryside and you
know there were times when we really
thought that when we were surprised by
how much could happen out there
oh we had no clue about one of the
things that we were most proud of the
stories that we were most proud of was
but was about the family planning
clampdown that took place
it began in 1991 and it led to the
forced sterilization of millions of
women basically there's a you know
there's a one-child policy in China
people are allowed based only one and
sometimes two and depending upon the
area remote if it's very remote three
children but because China Chinese
families especially in the countryside
they favor boys Oh
girls and so they if they only are
allowed one or two kids they want it to
be a boy lineages passed down through
the few males and daughters married
outside of the family so they want boys
so the result is that every year 1.7
million baby girls go missing some of
them are unreported some of them are the
Midwife takes the head of the newborn
baby and dunks it into a bucket of water
a lot are aborted I've done him even
before they are born because of the new
machine that is probably the most
remarkable and China having the most
pervasive influence and that's the
ultrasound Museum the Machine expectant
mothers go to the doctors and they're
not supposed to learn the sex of the
fetus but if they pay a bribe to the
doctor the doctor will tell them and if
it's a girl they usually abort it and
then after they've had maybe one or two
kids there the woman is forced to go
through a sterilization so we learned
about this we wrote about this and we
were very proud of it we learned about
it two years after the clamp that had it
had begun the Fallen community learned
about it two years after it had begun
and this no policy probably in in the
world affected so many people so
intimately as this family planning
clamped down you say that World Bank
figures show that by the year 2025 that
the population will go from 1.2 billion
to 1.6 billion this country will have
307 million in it and Japan will only
grow by two men at 127 million
what are those figures tell you well
they underscore the China doesn't have a
genuine population problem in every year
China adds to its population 16 million
people which is equivalent to the entire
population of Australia but you know
still again I started off fairly
sympathetic to China's population policy
and Mori went on the more I thought it
was a just tremendously brutal and not
worth it chapter 10 I'll show this
picture could you have in here book you
start off this with an excerpt rather
how would you describe it
startling one startling x-ray theme book
why because that just shows how far
China has come people think still have
this image of the Chinese as as prudish
people who who don't like to talk about
anything that touches touches on sex but
of course you know the population is
growing enormously so it does exist in
China and it exists in the literature
now this one a book that was written by
an author who actually has a fairly good
reputation for writing good fiction he
decided he wrote this book called wasted
capital and it's about the decadence
it's about the lewd lives of several
individuals and he just describes for
instance a woman dies some masturbating
with corncobs I mean it's just some of
the images are just outrageous and it
did very well in China
in the last few weeks and months that we
were there it was a hot seller and
authorities tried to ban it several
times finally they did that but there
were still a lot of copies that had
already gotten out your first book yes
what do you think of the process it was
a wonderful one you know we really
enjoyed the I mean really every part of
it pictures the editing cover everything
what are you thinking I really like it I
think it's I think it was just a
wonderful process here's your dedication
was this a hard choice no I mean our
parents had just been so supportive the
whole way through we wanted to recognize
them who is the what's the name on the
bottom she's my sister and why did is
she the one that's in Hong Kong no no
there's obviously not because she was
she died in nineteen eighties right she
was on that kale like the KL
double-oh-seven unfortunately what was
she going she was going to Hong Kong
and how old was she at the time she was
21
you did reference though in the book
that you have a sister in Hong Kong how
many how many children in the family for
what about Hong Kong what did you learn
about 1997 when it reverts to control of
the Chinese the wheel of Hong Kong so
much and we have great hopes for it but
I know the standard argument about why
the Chinese aren't gonna hurt it is you
know they don't want to kill the goose
that lays the golden egg and I remember
when Chris Patten who's the the British
the Briton who is going who went there
as to be governor of Hong Kong when he
arrived the Hong Kong officials were
telling him you know you can relax we're
not gonna hurt Hong Kong and we don't
want to kill the goose lays the golden
egg and his reply was the only reason
that expression came into existence is
because history is littered with the
carcasses of dead geese which is a
useful reminder still my bet is that
it's going to despite some troublesome
troubles still do pretty well I mean
already striking that Hong Kong is
really in many ways taking over southern
China rather than the other way around
you can get Hong Kong radio in in the
southern part of China you can get a
Hong Kong radio you can watch Hong Kong
television you can see Hong Kong movies
who's taking over who is really a
question will they be able to stop the
the satellite television in China
probably not there you know that they
can make announcements they can crack
down in one particular city or one
particular neighborhood but they're
really losing their ability to control
things more broadly an information
revolution has come to China how does
someone get a satellite dish oh well you
can go to a store and buy it then they
put down they put they enforce this they
try to enforce this new regulation where
you couldn't buy satellite dishes but
you could still get them you quote Alex
de Tocqueville you bring up James
Madison in this book what's the been you
talk about the civil society what's the
point the point is that China right now
although it doesn't have Jeffersonian
democracy there is a movement there
there is progress
Nik talked about cannibalism there is no
longer that kind of cannibalism there
but people are taking getting a larger
stake in the system
we have people now who are interested in
in you know in listening to talk radio I
mean talk negative radio is something
from the from the West it's a through
talk radio people are discussing
problems of romance they're talking
about the garbage collection the filthy
garbage that's all over the street why
doesn't someone clean up their
complaining delicately about officials
about their local officials people who
have done them wrong there is a new law
administrative law that allows people to
sue government bureaucracies tiny tiny
little changes but they are steps toward
a more freer more richer society next up
Japan why do you want to do that we're
captivated by the changes taking place
in Asia and we think that that will be
another vantage point to view this
friend and also another way of looking
at the various debates in this country
whether it's healthcare or crime I think
that Japan will offer some interesting
and illuminating lessons for us you're
learning Japanese
is it hard how are you how are you being
taught where I right now we're mostly on
the farm in Oregon and we're we have
teachers coming to the farm and so every
day five hours a day we just go through
the Japanese lessons one D report for
your pen in Japan Oh at the end of the
year and what are you looking forward to
what's the first thing you want to go
find out about um I suppose crime and
then now I'm really curious about what
it is about Japan that's responsible for
its very low crime rates and is that the
way the police are organized or the you
know the gun control I think that's
gonna be interesting how do you think
you'll be received in Japan versus how
you've been received in the United
States over you know being a Chinese
agent will be very interesting the
status of women of in in Japan of
courses is even worse than it is in
China and in China it's still pretty bad
I mean you know in China for thousands
of years women have been thought of as
nothing more than walking wombs and even
my grandmother
she had her feet bound and always walked
off very awkwardly and you would have
thought that after ten years of reform
15 years of reform in China that the
status of women would have risen
dramatically but in many ways it hasn't
you know you have the rise at the market
and with the rise of the market has come
sinister industries like for instance
you have a trade in copper you have a
trade in toys and clothes but you also
have a trade in women you have the trade
in wives businessmen and women they go
to villages in the countryside and they
recruit these uneducated peasant women
with the promise of better jobs and
higher pay and they transport them to
other areas remote areas of the country
where they don't know the local dialect
and in China if you don't speak the
local dialect you basically cannot
communicate and they sell them to
uncouth peasants and I know of one story
where a woman she tried to escape and
the peasant blinded her he gouged out
her eyes I mean that kind of stuff goes
on in in China one time this is the
cover of the book a struggle for the
soul of a rising power China wakes
authors Nicholas Kristof and his wife
Sheryl WuDunn thank you very much for
joining us thank you thank you
Nicholas D kristof and Sheryl wouldn´t
husband and wife were awarded the
Pulitzer Prize in 1990 for their
reporting on the Tiananmen democracy
movement in China and its oppression
China wakes is published by vintage
books an imprint of Random House visit
Random House calm for more information